pillon nous invitons les français à
visiter notre pays
bienvenue au cours des dernières années
le flux touristique n'a cessé
d'augmenter
il s'agit à la fois des voyages
effectués de la russie vers la france et
de la france vers la russie
bien sûr il y a plus de citoyens russes
qui voyage en france et cela pour des
raisons historiques mais en même temps
le nombre de citoyens français qui
visitent notre pays augmentent également
tous les ans nous disposons de données
pour les neuf premiers mois de l'année
dernière le nombre de français avoir
visité notre pays a été d'un peu plus de
190 et environ 10 % de plus que l'année
dernière
je nous assange ou encore les données
définitives et je pense que ces chiffres
seront plus élevés qu'en 2018
mais nous ne voulons pas nous arrêter là
j'en ai parlé aujourd'hui avec un
collègue toronto et nous pensons que nos
échanges touristiques devraient être
cohérent et contribuer au développement
des relations entre nos deux pays tiers
attachés les bourses tram
si tu te dis surtout que le tourisme
contribue énormément au renforcement des
relations entre nos pays au renforcement
des liens culturels qui ont déjà une
longue histoire
nous souhaitons que le niveau des
chances touristiques soient conformes
aux objectifs stratégiques que nos pays
se sont fixé et agathe marché et apporte
une contribution significative au
développement des relations entre nos
pays at il fait cela rapproche les gens
et dire que les relations soient plus
chaleureuses et que cela est une
influence positive sur les relations
entre la russie et la france chez nous
aimerions qu'il y ait plus de français
qui visitent il est trop beau pays
qu'ils se familiarisent avec son
histoire sa culture non seulement grâce
aux manuels aux oeuvres littéraires mais
qu'il est également leur propre
expérience
qu'ils voient tous par eux-mêmes qu'il
se promène dans les rues de la belle
ville de moscou et de saint-pétersbourg
li qiang qu'il fasse la connaissance de
notre belle nature ou le cas et nous
travaillons actuellement là dessus
aujourd'hui le chiffre d'un million des
chances touristique a été évoquée
saillour de l'esti fiscale et il ne nous
semble même pas trop ambitieux jeu léché
nous avons la décision du président du
sud vladimir king qui affirme dès le 1er
janvier 2021
donc dans moins d'un an le régime de
visa électronique entrera en vigueur sur
l'ensemble du territoire du tennis pur
inférieur de 16 jours et seront demain
c'est haro nous partons du principe que
la liste des yvelines n'est pas encore
approuvé pour l'année prochaine mais
nous espérons qu'elle restera au moins
la même que pour kaliningrad et
saint-pétersbourg minimum paquet ou
d'accident soit 53 pays y compris tous
les pays européens depuis l'été dernier
nous disposons d'un dispositif de bise à
l'échelon unique pour kaliningrad et
depuis septembre dernier
ce format fonctionne également pour
saint pétersbourg c'est un projet pilote
un dispositif pilote qui est en vigueur
uniquement sur le territoire de ces deux
régions des piles 2017
le dispositif des visas électronique
fonctionne sur le territoire de
vladivostok et surtout celui de
l'extrême orient citoyens française
maintenant visiter saint pétersbourg
ville
apprécié de tous est connu dans le monde
entier avec un visa électronique qui est
valable huit jours ce visa peut être
obtenu facilement sur le site du
ministère des affaires étrangères quatre
jours avant le voyage
il n'est pas nécessaire de s'adresser
aux services consulaires
il suffit de remplir un simple
formulaire sur le site d'obtenir une
confirmation après quoi les voyageurs
peuvent venir dans le pays
c'est vraiment très important pour nous
de dire aux gens à quel point la russie
est belle
ah et on peut voyager facilement dans
notre pays la russie c'est bien sûr la
place rouge et le kremlin mais ce n'est
pas tout c'est aussi moscou et
saint-pétersbourg des montagnes des
fleuves des lacs ifaci est échue
la nature est fantastique et jonché de
contrées inexplorées sig a donné au
groupe il y à beaucoup des destinations
comme par exemple la cam chat cas
célèbre dans le monde entier tous ces
volcans et des villes de l'extrême
orient puis vladivostok capitale de la
partie asiatique de la russie elle est
très populaire chez les touristes
provenant des pays asiatiques étaient
mis au vélo macheteau mais en même temps
je suis convaincu que cette ville peut
être tout aussi attractive auprès des
touristes européens car elle possède une
histoire riche et une atmosphère
merveilleuse la mer la nature magnifique
d'excellents restaurants et boutiques
j'aimerais aussi faire découvrir aux
touristes étrangers la clyde beaucoup on
a entendu parler c'est un endroit
véritablement unique dans la nature avec
ce plan de points in exclure a admis des
montagnes les rivières et des lacs nom
peut rester seul afin de se ressourcer
sa peau et les os x et ces régions sont
facilement accessibles grâce aux
liaisons de transport avec moi nous
souhaitons que les gens je suis bien
dans notre pays ne se limite pas le gt
moscou et saint pétersbourg il est clair
que si une personne voyage dans le pays
pour la première fois il faut voir ces
deux villes en premier car il est
possible de se déplacer très vite entre
nos deux capitales ce comme on les
appelle car les liaisons de transport le
permet
au mali mais on peut également passer
trois jours à battre ou trois jours à
saint-pétersbourg après quoi vous pouvez
aller ailleurs comme passer quelques
jours au bord d'un lac dans l'attelage
notre sibérie est un bel endroit
également avec le baïkal et il ya plein
de choses à voir et beaucoup d'histoires
à raconter ou et nous travaillons pour
que les voyages dans notre pays soit de
plus en plus facile la marche espagne et
oui les mots que les gens en garde les
souvenirs les plus vifs tout en assurant
leur confort et leur sécurité dominés
mais ça passe mais la machine est
mauvais ce que nous pouvons garantir
aujourd'hui et je rappelle qu'on peut
obtenir un visa électronique maintenant
pour d'hésiter kaliningrad une ville
historique très intéressante au bord de
la mer où on peut admirer des monuments
marquants de la culture allemande
il en va de même pour saint-pétersbourg
qui est un lieu à visiter absolument
pour toute personne qui souhaite voir le
monde et à partir de l'année prochaine
on pourra obtenir un visa électronique
permettant de voyager partout dans le
pays